starting with luke bryan he continues
the party at resorts world with added
show dates through the end of the year
luke is ready to play it again ah i'd
like to see what you did there jillian
has an exclusive
interview with the country superstar
check it out
welcome back to las vegas we're so
excited to have you here so how does it
feel to be back and what can we expect
this time around
well you know las vegas is um
it always has a nice little magic when
you when you get here and land you're
always excited to be here
to get to come to the adult
the adult playground and i'm i love to
play craps and blackjack so
i've already gotten me a couple
couple little gambling sessions in but
you know the main thing is just being on
stage and having fun here at resorts
world
song
i gotta ask you i saw you post on
instagram not too long ago you had a
sparkly laptop on top of the beer box
like what what set up are we working
with today are you doing okay over there
well that that sparkly laptop was not my
laptop and neither is this one so
you know you got to be careful and not
get judged not get judged for your
laptop
you go up on a catwalk and you're up top
tell me about that and how cool that is
for the fans up there to get to kind of
interact with you too
yeah the catwalk is designed you know
um
like i said when you're when you're up
in the top balcony and even the second
level mezzanine you know you're always
you're you know i feel like fans i
remember being a fan always wishing i
was on the front row or closer so when
i'm able to get when i'm able to get up
on that catwalk and actually go up to
the top of the theater and really bridge
the gap and the distance between me and
the fans you know the fans really
appreciate it you and your fellow
american idol judges all have shows in
las vegas can we ever expect any sort of
crossover are you ever here at the same
time
you know i would i've actually gotten to
see katie's um
um katy perry's show out here
um
hadn't seen lionel's las vegas show yet
but the bottom line is
you know i think over you know the the
life of our hopefully we can all get
together and maybe get in a room same
time one of these days but
but you know us we
we got to be you know internally
competitive so uh we we uh we're always
competing in some form or fashion what's
it like really just being in the city
and having no limits
well yeah that you know what i love
about the aspect of the theater here is
uh you know it's a big theater you know
it's 5 000 seats but it's very intimate
and i can sit at my piano and just start
playing any songs
that i want to play without limitations
i mean a lot of times we're playing
these big amphitheaters and stadiums and
we have curfews and
and and you know if we don't get off
stage at a certain time you know we'll
get fined the fact that we can come out
and just
kind of go off the cuff whenever i want
to is pretty special in the show too i
use little moments to really tell jokes
and talk to the crowd and cut up and
not try to be you know you can you could
be a little more um
not so serious out here in vegas
you can see luke bryan vegas through the
end of the year with performances on
november 30th december 2nd 3rd 7th 9th
and 10th tickets are available through
axs dot